I do have a new watch phone it saw the
fuzz watch one but it's the fuzz sad
screen watch phone from the company come
on and that is how it works
check it out you've got your analog
screen what you can do is get yourself a
digital screen as well oh this is cool
now that's just the watch feature of it
now let's get to the cooler stuff right
here in the corner you've got a camera
camera guys now when you want to make a
phone call of course you just go to the
phone screen and there it is this is
capacitive touch if you want to know
what that is that means you need to use
the tip of your finger not your
fingernail but the tip of your finger to
make a phone call the send keys right
here the end keys right there but you
could also use the Bluetooth headset to
make the call this has voice-activated
dialing so if you press the number right
here it'll tell you to say a command
right there please say a command and you
say the command and you make the phone
call this is an mp3 player as well
mp3 player is not the last and greatest
thing what it is is has tempered glass
on it so it's scratch resistant it'll be
hard to scratch this you're worried
about getting caught in the rain don't
be this is also water resistant as well
wow this is the magic phone when is it
coming up it's coming out later this
year out in Europe and how much will it
cost we're not sure yet